when her daughter did not return home
from school
four days later kim's boyfriend
contacted detectives and said that kim
had called him
that morning when she went missing
asking him to pick her up at the dairy
queen which is located directly across
the street from western high school
kim's boyfriend went to the dairy queen
at around 10 45 that morning and kim was
nowhere to be found
we were able to corroborate the
boyfriend's statements after
interviewing her classmates as a result
of all those interviews we were able to
determine that she had last been seen at
around 10 o'clock that morning at dairy
queen
on january 31st of 1979
detectives received a phone call from a
citizen who had located kim's school bag
containing her purse
gym clothes and school books
and they were on a travel lane on
decatur
near
charleston
for three weeks
detectives investigated kim's
disappearance however we were unable to
gather any leads
on february 20th lvmpd was contacted by
three juveniles
who had located kim bryant's body in a
desert area near buffalo in charleston
the lvmp the lvmpd homicide section
investigated this case for years
without being able to identify a suspect
as a result
kim's case was eventually classified as
a cold case homicide
for the past 42 years this case has been
reviewed by numerous lvmpd detectives
hoping to gather new leads
we have we originally recovered dna
evidence from the suspect at the time of
the murder however we were unable to
make an identification
if you remember earlier this year i
announced that we had solved a different
cold case homicide because of a generous
philanthropist
justin wu
who donated money for the lvmpd for
genealogical testing on cold case
homicides
after we solved that case justin
provided additional money
to help us solve even more cases
as a result of the additional funding we
sent kim's case to othram labs in texas
for additional dna genetic work
ten days ago we were notified that the
genealogical profile built by othrum
labs based on sperm recovered from the
body of kim bryant at autopsy
revealed that johnny blake peterson was
the person who kidnapped sexually
assaulted and murdered kim bryant
i'm now going to read a statement from
edward elliott who is kim's father
on behalf of my family i would like to
thank the lvmpd and investigator terry
miller and all the investigators who
have worked on this case over the past
42 years
i would also like to thank justin wu for
putting up the money which helped make
today's announcement possible
kim was a beautiful girl with a bright
future and it makes me happy that
something is being done to help solve
cases such as hers
with that i'm going to turn it over to
justin
wu for a couple comments
first off condolences to kim's family we
hope that we provided a little bit of
closure for you um it's been an honor to
work with the las vegas metro pd and
other labs in helping the community
solve some of these cold cases i'm proud
to announce that we have a new
initiative called the vegas justice
league that we'll be launching it's a
community leaders within las vegas who
are banding together to help the metro
on some future cases so we have a lot of
cases lined up and we hopefully will
have a lot of solves for the lv metropd
in the future so looking forward to
working with you guys on that and
congratulations thank you
thank you
i want to briefly speak about the
suspect in this case
we have conducted an extensive
investigation into johnny blake
peterson's background and learned that
he resided in las vegas at the time of
kim's death and at one point he attended
western high school
in 1980 in april of 1980 peterson was
arrested for a sexual assault that
occurred in the las vegas area but that
case was dismissed
johnny blake peterson died on january
20th of 1993
therefore there will be no arrests made
on this murder
the las vegas metropolitan police
department and the lvmpd homicide
section want to express their sincere
gratitude to both justin wu and othram
labs for their generous financial
donations and efforts in helping us
solve these cold case homicides
we continue to work diligently on all
cold case homicides in an effort to
provide
closure and resolution not just to the
victims families but the entire las
vegas community as a whole
so again
thank you both uh we are not here in a
without the donation and the kindness
and the hard work of the labs and mr wu
and all the investigators and forensic
scientists that have worked with us
throughout the years to bring closure to
the bryant
bryant family so with that i'll take a
couple questions if you have them
this one is for justin and yourself talk
a little bit about 32 years later the
importance of continuing to pursue cases
like this in the las vegas valley you
know it's one of the things i'm most
proud about with our section uh when you
deal with some of the most horrific
crimes that this valley sees nothing
frustrates me more than when we're not
able to solve
a case you know we again i've you've
heard me mention it multiple times we
have the highest solvability rate of any
major city law enforcement but besides
that there's still cases that we can't
solve so when you're
able to look back 42 years and bring
some closure to a family nothing's going
to make the pain go away but at least
the family has some closure and i want
the community to know that that we never
stop working these cases and never stop
following up on every lead and that's
what makes this announcement today uh so
important because you know as soon as i
walk away from this podium today and our
detectives walk back to our office we're
back to working on the next solve that
we can make justin did you have uh
yes
which school did the victim go to and
the suspect go to and do you believe
that he knew her from that interaction
so we know at one point the suspect did
go to western high school she
was a student at western high school
were looking to see if there was any
interaction at the time of her death
he was not a student at that school
however we can't rule out if there was
any type of interaction previously we
are looking into it i know you put out a
statement from the victim's father
did you inform him that you've made an
arrest or could you describe that moment
when
your people called him and let him know
so you know i always let the lead
detectives make those notifications
because these detectives work tirelessly
and that's the reason they're here doing
this job and they you know that's the
satisfaction that they get so i can tell
you when the lead detective did reach
out to the family
you know there's there's closure but
again it doesn't bring their daughter
back and
you know it's
it's the hardest part of this assignment
is when you deal with the families you
know we do everything we can to solve
the cases but again you're dealing with
families that have been devastated and i
can't imagine the the pain and the loss
that they've gone through in the back
what age was the suspect at the time
so she was 16 he was 19.
he was a suspect at one point
what happened so just to clarify he was
never on the radar as a suspect we had
no
it for this
murder
so
we had dna that we had recovered that
was showing there was no match for the
dna
so in that regards we were unable to
uh link the two
so
yes
so i i do want to speak real quick
briefly michael vogen he is with other
labs he made the trip here to las vegas
on behalf of the lab and he's going to
answer a little bit of scientific
questions where he can answer that for
you real quick as far as
hello my name is michael vogen i'm the
director of case management at authorum
we built author just a couple years ago
from the ground up to be a completely
full service end-to-end forensic lab
that works exclusively with folks like
the las vegas metro pd to identify
perpetrators of crime and also
jane john and baby does so because we
have this end-to-end process we access
tens of thousands to hundreds of
thousands of markers of dna which when
you build that profile enables you to
upload those into various databases
where you can find distant relatives and
include or exclude out as being related
to your source and i know kim you may
have something to add to that
yes my name is kim merga i'm the
director of laboratory services for the
las vegas metropolitan police department
just to kind of tag on to what was just
said the lvmpd brought on dna
in june of night of 1999
we then obtained codis in april of 2001
but dna continues to evolve in becoming
more and more sensitive so we first
attempted dna on this particular case
back in 2008 we were not able to get a
dna profile
technology has continued to advance and
revolutionized we again attempted dna on
different items of evidence in january
of this year we were able to obtain a
foreign male dna profile and some
evidence and we put that dna profile
into codis the combined dna index system
and at that time we obtained no hits so
we were aware that if we obtain no hits
from a 1979 cold case homicide we're
probably not going to get any hits and
that's why we thought it would be a
wonderful case to turn over to have
advanced genetic genealogy testing
performed on
yes do we have the indication how many
examples similar to this there are still
out there that could be run and lead
the best cases for genetic genealogy are
cases that have reached a dna dead end
meaning that we have a dna profile we
believe to be from a suspect but we've
put them into the combined dna index of
the codis database and we have no hits
we did run a query we have about a
hundred plus cases that are cold case
homicides in which we have developed dna
profiles but we have have had no hits we
are working with our cold case homicide
team to evaluate those cases and also
for resources to get them sent out to
otherum labs and we're also looking at
expanding not only solving cold case
homicides but cold case sex assaults as
well so we are also working with our
cold case sex assault detectives to
evaluate cases that we may have a
suspect dna identified in one or
multiple cases and we're looking to
start sending those out as
real quick well great that mr movement
has come forward to provide resources
for this but what kind of resources
would you need to kind of clear that
cache
well it's really a case-by-case basis so
there is the cost of doing the thousands
of genetic marker testing and other labs
and other similar labs but then there's
also the genealogist component which can
be
add up if they have to do extensive
evaluation of different records that may
be available i don't have an exact
figure but i know through generous
donations as well as working with our
own department we will continue to send
out these cases as long as resources are
available in the hopes of solving some
of these cold
passed over cases years ago how did you
find his dna to make that match where
did it come from how do you draw that
bridge
so we have on all homicide
investigations even when the case is
still being worked and evidence was
collected back in 1979 all of that
evidence is still stored in our evidence
vault so
just because we're not actively
testing it doesn't mean we still have
that evidence so we're able to go back
pull the evidence and look for
so
so his dna was recovered at autopsy from
sperm that was recovered during autopsy
that is where the dna link was made
yes
how are you able to take that i think
that's the suspect who died years ago
was his dna already in the system or was
the family member
you want me to let you
answer that
so basically when we developed the
profile of this unknown suspect and we
created that large profile that i
mentioned had all those markers of dna
we upload that in various databases and
we find distantly related people to that
dna and we slowly include or exclude
them as being closely regulated and we
work that family tree until we get to a
point that we then go back to the
investigators and say hey here's some
information on some people that if you
got their date of birth where their
families from where their parents were
born and give that back to us we can
start filling holes of the puzzle and
then it's basically confirmed
with kim's lab where we found a relative
that i believe was willing to test
and they gave a sample and then we could
detect the familial relationship
right correct
if i can follow on that what resources
do you use
so it's important to point out we do
what what is called forensic grade
genome sequencing that's the process
name that we use and we develop those
profiles for the various databases gen
match family tree dna we have our own
called dna solves and people either opt
in or opt out depending on the database
that they're in to help search against
law enforcement cases
that's right
so at this point we are looking at any
potential other cases that he could be
involved in
there again it's still very early on i
will tell you that there is the
possibility
that we are looking or we are looking at
and there is that possibility so there's
a couple cases that
are getting a spotlight right now
that are potentially
related but we're still too early to
link that one last question
so
again he lived in las vegas at the time
uh
that the murder occurred there was
criminal activity that he was involved
in
throughout
that time again i mentioned the sexual
assault in 1980 there's some other
property type crimes and drug-related
offenses
that he was involved in
yes here prior to his death so again
thank you everyone for coming out we
appreciate it and have a great afternoon